let me get obsessed with romance I think
it also comes from the nicknames we got
growing up with my dad growing up called
me princess right princess he'd roll
into my head as a kid then I'm African
princess and then I grew up and out of
the real world and I realized that no
one else was on board the whole princess
thing right princesses don't lose their
virginity at Lollapalooza that's just
not I think we need to start calling it
things to prepare them for real life you
know get in the car rehab let's go
when we could call things and make them
obsessed with romance guys could call
things the big expensive sports right
you guys get calls like champ sport
you guys are so obsessed with sports you
made skating refer to increments of a
relationship without referring to sports
right first base we got to second base
they gonna see women running around
referring increments of our
relationships through things we like
it's not like last night me and Mark
Chanel purse you guys are so obsessed
with sports you guys will wear jerseys
for teams that you're not even on but
you think you're on the team
you'll be like yeah last night I guess
we just didn't score enough last night I
guess we just in plain of defense we the
Redskins don't need you
okay that's like me watching Grey's
Anatomy in scrubs
you